begin this hour with gillane maxwell who
is now convicted sex trafficker and may
spend the rest of her life in prison
after deliberating for five days a jury
in new york city found maxwell guilty of
five of the six charges against her they
include sex trafficking of a minor
transporting a minor with intent to
engage in criminal sexual activity and
three counts of conspiracy all in
connection with her friend and companion
jeffrey epstein maxwell's lawyers say
they'll appeal u.s attorney damien
williams praised the verdict
i want to commend the bravery of the
girls now grown women who stepped out of
the shadows and into the courtroom
maxwell who turned 60 on christmas day
is also awaiting trial and perjury
charges a sentencing date has not yet
been set one of epstein and maxwell's
many accusers who was not part of this
criminal case is with us sarah ransom
says she was recruited into epstein's
sex trafficking ring in 2006 when she
was 22 years old ransom tells her story
in the book silence no more surviving my
journey to hell and back she settled a
civil suit against epstein and maxwell
in 2018. sarah ransom is with us this
morning sarah thank you so much you are
truly a survivor do you feel vindicated
this morning
i do feel vindicated and
well
i feel completely overwhelmed for a
start and i never thought this day would
ever happen and i just
for me it's really important to thank
the prosecutors
and to thank the four incredibly brave
beautiful women that testified
because without them
without their truth
we would never have got gilan behind
bars we would never have had this
verdict so
um
yes this is justice but this is just the
beginning
that's i have to imagine with feeling
that way there is a long road ahead now
because there are others uh potentially
involved here i do want to go back to
what you said for a second about those
four women who testified um you said in
an interview with one of our colleagues
gayle king earlier
when she interviewed you that you said
that justice for you would mean that she
spends uh her life behind bars
does that seem like a real possibility
now
i mean just just the mere thought of
that i just
i mean it's so mind-boggling it still
hasn't dawned on me that justice has
finally been served it's
you know it's been such a long hard
journey to get here
so yesterday's decision i think will
take um
a little while to to sink in
but um
the thought of guillain spending the
rest of her life behind bars
you know you must understand she
she destroyed
so many hundreds if not thousands
of other women young women and children
you know so
i'm i'm pleased that she will never
she'll never be out again ever to hurt
anybody else and for that i feel very
pleased
and that's when you it really was
because of those four women who
testified a big chunk of this you said
in 2017
you sued epstein and maxwell settle with
them for an undisclosed amount of money
you have said in the past that you wish
that you had had your day in court
how do you feel now
well i sort of did have my day in court
you know these these brave women gave me
my day in court you know and that's why
it was so important for for me to be
there in new york during the trial
and
you know i
i got that moment with elaine
um on closing arguments i sat um
a verb behind
elaine's family and
i had that eye connection with gilean
and
i'll never forget when she forced me
into a room to be raped by jeffrey and
the way she smiled
and
now
guillen will remember
that look when i sat behind her family
for the rest of her life and it's just a
wonderful feeling
was it hard for you to be in court
i was terrified you know i mean you know
i think of myself as brave and strong
and i
i remember the the morning before um
i i was finally
finally uh able to get into the main
courtroom and i just i was terrified but
then
you know when i sat there
and saw her for what she really is
she looked pathetic
absolutely pathetic and it was worth
every single dollar
i spent being in new york
and it will be a moment i will treasure
for the rest of my life it was worth
every
moment
it sounds like a very powerful moment
for you
um in your mind do you feel she's worse
than epstein
yes i do
you're so sorry yes i do
um
women are supposed to look after each
other
human beings are supposed to look after
each other
and
because she was a woman she normalized
abuse
she participated
she tortured
me and and
and others and
she's worse than jeffrey she broke the
sisterhood
she broke that bond
she was supposed to be a protector and
nurturer
and she failed us
and she'll have to live with that for
the rest of her life
sarah i can only imagine how hard this
is for you and in the past you've talked
about victim shaming and there was a lot
of victim shaming for years uh when
talking about jeffrey epstein and glenn
maxwell
do you feel that talking about this
today hearing this verdict writing your
book
um
do you feel like it's part of your
healing process
i am a completely different woman from
when i started writing the book to the
woman i am now
i
the book for me
was not only about my personal growth it
was about me taking responsibilities for
for
some of the mistakes i've made and
i have been called every single name
under the sun i mean you name it i've
been called it and you know what it's
it's actually made me unbreakable and
that was a reason why i wrote the book
because yes i've made so many mistakes
i'm a human being who doesn't
um i don't go out harming anybody the
only person i harmed was myself
but it doesn't mean
that i i'm not
i'm not a victim of rape or sex
trafficking
so
you know the victim shaming needs to
stop
and i hope that my my book has in some
way paved the way
for other victims to go you know what
it doesn't matter if i did this or that
i'm still a victim
i i still deserve a voice i still
deserve to be heard
and and my book
you know i just want if i can do
anything
is to just say
don't be silence silence no more
you know we are in a new era
you know this
this case with gillane is absolutely
groundback-breaking
this is history-making
and i think
you know this is an example that
you know the powerful the wealthy
you can't behave like this
you will eventually be stopped
and i hope people think
really long and hard
next time they want to hurt another
human being
sarah so many important messages and
what you're talking about this morning
thank you so much for sharing your story
we appreciate you being here
thank you very much thank you